هذه المدينه التي تعتبر من اكثر المدن
تضررا بفعل الزلزال التي ضرب هذه المنطقه
نحن تحديدا في المقبره حيث يقوم الاهالي
بدفن الضحايا في قبور جماعيه حيث يتعذر ان
يدفنوا كل شخص على حده بسبب العدد الكبير
للضحايا في هذه المدينه التي حتى الان
هنالك اكثر من 70 شخصا قد قتل جراء هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه عوائل باكملها
يتم دفنها في قبور جماعيه التقينا هنا
بهذا الرجل الذي يحدثنا عن عن افراد
عائلته الذين فقدهم نتيجه هذا الزلزال
الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمكم
ويحفظكم يا رب واجركم ان شاء الله
نحن نقول الحمد لله على ما قدر علينا فقد
ولدي همام وابنائه الاربعه وابنتي
واولادها الثلاث كم شخص تقريبا
اخي وبناته الثلاثي
ابن اخي واولاده الاربعه وزوجته ابن اخي
الاخر واولاده الثلاث فالعدد عندك صار انا
ما احصيت العدد لكن اخي فعلا جنديرس اصيبت
بكارثه ونحن نطلب من كل المعنيين ان يقفوا
الى جانب اهلهم والى جانب اخوانهم
في فكلنا معرض لمثل ما حدث ولكن الذي حدث
كارثه في في سعدات كثير من الضحايا موجوده
هناك تحت الانقاض الكثيرين ما استطاعت
يعني العدد كبير والابنيه التي سقطت على
الارض كثيره جدا فنحتاج فعلا نحتاج الى
كوادر احتاج الى اليات
جاء الدفاع المدني لم يقصر والفصائل هنا
لم تاتي
امر يحتاج الى الى الى جهد كبير
هكذا يبدو المشهد هنا في هذه في هذه
المكان في جنديرس هنالك اعداد كبيره من
الضحايا بعضهم يتم دفن في قبور جماعيه
هنالك اعداد اخرى ما يزالون تحت الانقاض
يحاول الدفاع المدني بمتوفر لديه من ادوات
ان يستخرجهم من تحت الانقاض الدفاع المدني
يقول بان الصوره في هذه المنطقه وفي عموم
شمال غربي سوريا الوضع كارثي نظرا لقله
المساعدات او لعدم وصول المساعدات اصلا
ولانه لا يستطيع ان يقوم
بعمليه استخراج الضحايا من تحت الانقاض
بالادوات المتوفره لديه فحسب عمر حلبي
الجزيره من ناحيه جنديرس ريفوحلا